This episode is sponsored by 80,000 Hours. 80,000
Hours is a nonprofit that aims to help people have
a positive impact with their career. Head to
80000hours.org/microcosmos to start planning
a career that could potentially help solve
one of the world’s most pressing problems.
From our vantage point, as relatively large
organisms, it can be easy to overlook the
microcosmos, because it is simply too small
to see. It floats in front of our eyes at
all times, and yet we cannot make out
any of the details until we turn to other tools.
And then, even when we do turn to those
tools, it can be easy to overlook the
parts of the microcosmos that seem relatively
understated compared to all of the wondrous,
dramatic events that can take place. After all, if
you’ve just come from, say, watching a tardigrade
wandering through a maze of moss…you might find
something like this a bit underwhelming.
There’s just some squishy dots, floating around,
not doing anything particularly noteworthy except
for a few brief flashes of movement. The movement
is so quick that you might see it and just move
on to something else, like when you glimpse
a bird flying out of the corner of your eye.
It captures your attention for a second,
and perhaps releases it just as quickly.
But for today, because we are us, we're gonna
lingeron that moment and let it capture our
attention a little longer. Because the organism
you’relooking at now is a ciliate called Cyclidium,
which is known for its ability to dart straight
through the microcosmos like an arrow. It’s
only a few micrometers in length, but packed
in its small body is the ability to detect
threats and quickly jump out of their reach.
This is not the first time we’ve seen a very,
very fast-moving ciliate on this channel
before. Early on, we watched as bundles of
the bell-shaped Vorticella extended
their long stalks and then rapidly
contracted those stalks into tightly-packed
spirals when other organisms got too close.
We’ve also watched a Spirostomum quickly evade
unwanted contact, pulling back and shrinking down
to get itself out of reach as quickly as possible.
We can think of the vorticella and spirostomum as
doing something that’s more like flinching, a
rapid contraction that moves them away from a
potential threat, but that doesn’t necessarily
transport them to a whole new location.
It’s remarkable and requires both tremendous
force and speed. But ciliates like the cyclidium
we were watching earlier or these Halteria are
performing a very different sort of athleticism,
something, more like a long jump.
Not that they look like they should be
setting any records. Halteria are only
around 20 microns in length, and most of
the time they just kind of spin, like a kid on
a teacup ride with no concept of dizziness.
And charmingly, the halteria is
edged in cilia that swirls with it,
unfurling as it moves, and then wrapping
back inward as the organism winds down.
Halteria like to feed on bacteria, and
they reproduce quickly. So sometimes,
James, our master of microscopes, will
find thousands of them in a single drop,
another set of squishy dots
that move in and out of focus,
sometimes even obscuring the other interesting
bits that James is trying to look at.
But let’s zoom out, past the point where we can
see the defined lines of the Halteria’s cilia,
where it really is just one dot navigating a field
of debris. And see if you can keep up with it.
Most of the time, it’s not really a challenge.
It looks like a floater in your vision,
a clear blob that just idles away.
But then, seemingly out of nowhere,
it leaps across the screen and out of view,
potentially traveling as far as 100 times
its own body length in a single second. That
would be like if I, a 6 foot humanbeing,
could leap 600 feet in a second.
In response, you might say something like,
“Okay, yeah, sure Hank, but you’re a human
being. Things are different
in the microcosmos.” And yes, this is true.
Things really are different in the microcosmos.
In fact, things are a lot more challenging. Organisms
like halteria are living in water, but because of
their small size, that water feels thick like
molasses. So, they have to rely on structures
like cilia to help them swim and move quickly.
But even then, most organisms only travel around
10 times their body length in a single second.
The fact that halteria and a select group of other
leaping ciliates are able to jump 100 times their
body length in that same second is incredible.
And we don’t know exactly what it is that makes these
impressive hops possible. But it does require
a lot of energy, so it makes
sense that in its off moments,
the halteria prefers to be a little more static.
And there are a few other members of this elite
jumping ciliate group, like the Strombidium
you see here leaping around. It is very impressive
that James can even keep up with them.
And that of course is the point.
Not to avoid James, the ciliates are not
aware of him. But the goal of this movement
is to help the ciliate be overlooked, to
ensure that predators can’t find them.
And it works. The slightest brush of a
predator’s presence sends these ciliates
into escape mode. In one experiment, researchers
set some rotifers upon a population of Halteria
and found that only around 12% of them ended up
as rotifer food. Another leaping ciliate called
Strobilidium was even more successful at evading
capture, with only 3% of them getting eaten.
There is however one notable exception to this
predator evasion. While Halteria might be able to
escape rotifers, they have a dedicated predator
called the Actinobolina, which we’ve talked about
before. This tentacled, toxin-loaded ciliate could
go after anything it wanted. But for some reason,
it dines exclusively on Halteria.
Why? And how?
No clue. Maybe they just got lucky to live in an
environment that was rich enough in Halteria that
through evolution, the Actinobolina was able
to learn how to sneak up on their cagey prey.
So perhaps it is not possible for them
to always be overlooked. Eventually,
someone will take a moment to appreciate them.
If they are unfortunate, it is the one predator
that has managed to find a way around their
tricks. But sometimes it’s just us, slowing down
just enough to catch a glimpse of something
so much faster… and so much smaller… than we are.
Thanks for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thanks again to 80,000 Hours
for sponsoring today’s episode.
80,000 Hours is a nonprofit that aims to help
people have a positive impact with their career.
The direction of your career path is
a big life decision and 80,000 hours
has a lot of free resources to help you plan
and research what options might be best for you.
They’ve got fantastic, free resources including
decision-making tools, a constantly updated job
board, and even a podcast where they have in-depth
conversations with experts in the world’s most
pressing problems, and discuss what you can
do to help solve them. In one of their recent
episodes they discussed what’s being done on the
cutting edge of malaria control and treatment,
and the state of the art efforts that are going
towards trying to create a malaria-free world
80,000 Hours wants to help
you find a career that does
good in the world and all of their provided
resources are free! They’re a non-profit,
and their only aim is to help you
find a fulfilling, high-impact career.
Check out our link in the description or go
to 80000hours.org/microcosmos to be sent
a free copy of their in-depth career
guide to start learning how you could
have a high-impact career. This will
also sign you up for their newsletter,
where they send updates on their research
and high impact job opportunities
All of the names on the screen right now are
the names of people who decided that they
would be a reason why Journey to
the Microcosmos is able to exist
and keep making such delightful
little bits of content as this one.
So if you’re looking for someone to
thank, it’s these folks right here.
And if you’re interested in becoming one,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.